and bridges with the free throw 17 to 8
[Applause]
sorts with the spin throw it up let
Anthony Davis throw it down he cans that
played that ad made prime example go up
get contact with the ball without
getting too much contact with the
offensive player P Davis hit the good
handle working across the time line he's
in the attacking 47 he's gonna take it
all the way in he took the rebound went
the distance themselves a couple of
Kentucky guys going at each other right
there for the easy easy layup or threes
the other night Moore made threes ladies
did a try one
for Anthony day that every phase of the
game can be dominant through a jab step
get to defend the back bounce to ad pick
it into the corner Bradley for three
weeks has Reva a good one by 80 to
finish it on the cleanup with a minute
to play nothing to give either side
quick cook down the bill
[Applause]
just tracking first-look was the dunk by
ad laid it on the left side because he's
so good now off the dribble getting to
the middle it gets bigger than Janice
that back in because six watch this
40:33 wears up by the honest Jana State
to Kevin Love forcing to throw away
let's oh yeah that's time
like it does
[Music]
that was open up some room for Bledsoe
underneath that ended in run by the
Cavaliers
the bunch have scored the last four
Yanis on a hammer will he do it again or
get close again to a triple-double
Anthony Davis number one pick in the
draft
out of Kentucky LBJ also a number one
pick bouncing off the glass store and
one LeBron Davis the combo works again
but they will I don't know how you play
that one because if there's a good
screen one of those two were going to
end up with and we'll take us through
the glass to seed how great that play
was look at this pass look at this
reception and finish at some play by ad
and he was actually looking for a foul
didn't get it but he'll take the basket
in go to the other way shuttle found
that last play where kcp ends up with
the assist as they scramble to have the
court wide open
draaga moving the ball a hundred Davis
[Music]
[Applause]
the pianos like horridly bro by 504
Antonia Davis is so Kabira liquors also
have instances over much padishah car
tour visit out you to the media he's
tough on this side stays with it he gets
to he goes one way or spins back and he
sat right here fries and layups that's
what the league is and mr. [ __ ] to come
flow gets right to the front of it spin
you know it's coming so you react a
little bit late he gets right between
you you know that spin is coming Marcus
took away that side anticipate first
team All Defense a season to go be
honest on the baseline in the punch with
the left take is okay Yanis he drives he
kicks it out now look what Korver
catches his ball I mean look at that
shot well if you saw a pregame show you
saw speak with Marcus smart about the
chemistry on this team and how Egan put
stop that at 10 a cool pull off the law
freeze and Brook Lopez in the pain a
little bit
he'll slow on the recovery
first field goal for Yanis identical bow
a dead Akuma Dave watch Evan for Nia is
gonna square him up he'll take the hit
and then into great balance and watch
boots just he just steps right by him
not a lot of contact there but enough
and he's added strength every year watch
the hip I mean he was there you see the
contact and he's still able to pop what
did they go up when we did the [ __ ] it
to George Hill yeah that's with the
steel striding over the back of
Rodriguez 73
[Music]
yes
shooting over the top of the meter a
Goomba not many people have the ability
to crowd him so you give him space but
this is what you end up with James on
the LOB and Davis Samba throwdown
not Luke adoptions back in his well
Anthony Genesis is certainly back on the
floor Davis facing up barrel ahead
that's throwing it down with authority
comes James James motoring missed it
Davis didn't he's had in this particular
instance he uses his face up game
because Powell does a good job cutting
him off and the captures out at 15 feet
squares him up gets a little bit of
separation
he didn't never had his three game
working Anthony David you better not
break down mentally exist abroad cuz he
will make one trouble pretty much
anywhere Clause half court and siakam
things easily
Fowler get on the floor but he does not
miss by AB and bleep like baboons
wearing a pair of hair Hoppus catches
that cow not that kind of
ability
Toronto shot tonight there was a timeout
taken 48:25 Milwaukee at 5:00 surf bar
on the anis getting it done to kick out
he was having none of it just able to
get himself around the outstretched arms
of Gasol just enough you won't sag is so
bitter though when they hire themselves
it's amazing they Vincenzo in the middle
of the qiyan but it was any part of that
one two three Smirnoff each level my
stomach reach assistance in a little
bottle hormones ACK about septic oh boy
dick blowing barking Beth big brother
sits Yanis trailing siakam not quitting
on the play hesitation that's a great
thing about that for heaven is that that
was like I have to jack the shot clock
was about it to stuff with the offensive
rebound
regret so I'm going to have a triple out
on him you see got us dead sprint digs
it out
finish two movies don't even touch it
and pull down you you have to maintain
contact he got me
oh it's nothing that Josh can do and try
to strip them down low
see the size difference as good as
giannis was last year in winning the MVP
gym is up to an even better so they get
to protect the pain a lot of teams of in
vain tried to guard hit the free-throw
upcoming but not before a timeout on the
floor
Bucs leading at 5-4 late the second city
didn't use it then off arm this time but
he'd need him right in the stomach and
he was right there
that is completely giving up his body
there's no question that the ball is
still in Yanis his hands get done is to
stepping right around trivial graham i
mean jumping look how far away PE chops
outside the restricted area